all right naturally I have to start this
week by talking about the horrific
attacks in Paris a few days ago sadly it
seems to me that these attacks are
becoming all too common these days and
each event continues in the path of
carnage and absolute savagery these
Islamic extremists want to impose on the
Western world yeah I did say Islamic
extremists there I know that upset some
and makes the politically correct crowd
uncomfortable but unfortunately the more
we ignore the very set of ideas these
people tell us that they're using to
attack us the more we actually
strengthen them this is what my former
guests Majin Waze told me he refers to
as the Voldemort effect
JK Rowling described this idea in Harry
Potter books as quote fear of a name
only increases fear of a thing itself
are there any other ideas we should be
afraid of talking about I can't think of
any and I refuse to treat this one idea
differently we can't be afraid of scary
things especially in idea form because
that's how they will grow and morph
right in front of our eyes and of course
by saying these people who committed
these specific horrific acts were
Islamist extremists it obviously doesn't
condemn all Muslims if at this point you
can understand that distinction perhaps
there's a cat video out there better
suited for you than what we're doing
here I mentioned a couple weeks ago how
I'd like to move a bit away from talking
about the regressive left while I still
want to do that I feel like the
regressives are a lot like the Mafia the
more I try to get out the more they pull
me back in case in point the response by
many of the regressives immediately
after the attacks was to blame u.s.
foreign policy rationalizing we
ourselves are to blame for the people
who chose to murder over a hundred
innocent civilians after talking to my
last two guests Douglas Murray and
Faisal Syed Ali Matar I've come to
believe this is an incredibly dangerous
and egotistical Lee driven view of the
world to the regressives everything
revolves around us people only do things
as a reaction to us so even though these
terrorists say they're doing this in the
name of religion and point to the actual
texts that prove it well according to
the regressives
they just don't know what they're
talking about
that said as Maajid mentioned and as
I've been saying repeatedly two things
can be true at once it can be true that
there is an ideology out there a book
written by men a long time ago that
gives plenty of reasons to kill all
infidels and at the same time it can be
true our Western foreign policy created
massive instability in their part of the
world and perhaps if we left Saddam and
power Isis never would've arose every
action leads to consequences often
unintended ones sometimes America does
good things sometimes America does bad
things but thinking it's all about us
all of the time seems more like how a
child would think of the world then how
an adult would approach the problem of
course none of this will stop the
regressives from laying blame solely on
America and its allies the 'some Boldin
about the extremists themselves and
those on the far right I've been trying
to have discussions on this show so
people can see that there are others out
there who understand the nuance and
complexity of these very difficult
issues we don't have all the answers but
we aren't afraid to have the
conversations that most people won't
touch let's pretend for a second that
all of the world's issues were a hundred
percent because of America and we did
exactly what ever it is Isis would want
us to do would that make us any safer
actually I'm pretty sure we do the exact
opposite by holding the Western world in
a perpetual hostage crisis with the same
people who have an old text to justify
just that final thought on this I'm
really not trying to score cheap
political points here by constantly
calling out their aggressive I'm trying
to lay out a case to show you guys that
the left is in real danger because of
the regressives misguided
head-in-the-sand politically correct
brand of demagoguery at the end of the
day I blame these attacks on nobody
other than the sick twisted people who
committed these horrific acts of
violence at the same time I won't stop
speaking up against the misguided ideas
that will only bring about more of these
acts because we are afraid to look at
the whole picture and not just our
narrow myopic view of the world my guest
this week is Sarah hater Sarah is the
co-founder of X Muslims of North America
an organization which advocates for the
acceptance of
dissent promotes secular values and aims
to reduce discrimination of those who
leave Islam also according to her
Twitter bio she is Pakistani by birth an
American by choice Sarah welcome to the
show thank you for having me here Dave
it's really good to be here
so I'm so glad we finally connected
because we've been going back and forth
for a couple months and we seem to be
sort of swimming in the same circles so
to speak lately and I love that line
let's just start with that line on your
Twitter bio Pakistani by birth an
American by choice why do I do you put
that in there well well a lot of people
don't know about me is that I am an
immigrant and I think that's a big part
of my story and in addition I think that
the American by choice means a lot
because there are so many things about
America that I love there are so many
values that are that are truly American
that I think are wonderful and in so
many left-wing circles it's
unfashionable to say anything positive
about America at all
and I hope to be able to swim against
that tide a little bit yeah I'm pretty
sure that as an immigrant that's doing
good things in this country you're
allowed to maybe kind of say something
nice about America are you a neocon now
well apparently if you ask certain
people I am but I think that you know it
took me so long to be able to get this
citizenship I only got it this year and
now I am fully an American citizen and I
feel so happy about it because this is a
country I know so much about and I spent
my entire you know most of my life here
and I feel so strongly that I am part of
the American fabric and I want to
contribute to it however I can yeah well
obviously I love all that and where I
really became familiar with you was back
in May when you gave this speech at the
American Humanist Association which was
really brilliant stuff but I want to
start first with a little bit of your
history when did you and your family
come here from Pakistan when did you
sort of have your secular awakening that
kind of thing well I think I was about
eight years old
when I came to America and I remember I
remember this being you know a very
strange and new country for me I
remember learning the language and I
remember thinking it was very strange um
I
I struggled a little bit in the first
few years but then there was so much
about America that I thought was just
wonderful and I mean these concepts that
we have that we take for granted like
individual liberty and right to free
speech and all these things I mean these
don't exist in any form in so many parts
of the world so act that we haven't you
know and I saw this with new eyes at hey
here you can say anything I mean not
anything truly but in a way that in a
way that isn't just comparable to
anywhere else and uh so anyway I became
really immersed into American government
and I thought it was really wonderful
the way that you know the separation of
powers the Bill of Rights I thought that
was just fantastic stuff and when I was
about 16 15 years old I began to have
doubts about my faith and a lot of it
had to do with actually I mean just
debating and seeing new viewpoints I was
on the debate team that helped what did
push me a little bit I think was meeting
what you would call militant atheists
you know the obnoxious oh yeah
they're the worst those militant
atheists yeah violent right and the
people that would you know get in your
face and there was one guy in particular
I knew a few but there was one guy in
particular who would print out verses
from the Quran that were just horrible
right these horrible verses and he would
just hand them to me and not say a word
and just be like this is look at this
and you know this was my first time
really really looking into it and I
think this is the case for so many
Christians and Jews and Muslims who
leave religion that they were like well
you know when I really looked into it it
didn't make a lot of sense or there was
some horrible stuff in there right for
me it was kind of a quest to prove these
atheist wrong you know and I started
doing research online because I was sure
that that Islam was the way and Islam
was so good for women and women's rights
and all of the stuff could be explained
when looked into context and then I
looked at the context sometimes I made
things worse so then I thought okay well
time to admit defeat and it didn't
really take me a long time before I
thought this too
doesn't make any sense it's not honest
for me to say that I am a Muslim given
that I know all this now yeah I love
that you describe the militant atheist
what did they have they had photocopied
paper that was their weapon you know you
may be the other extremist they have
some more serious stuff like you're
gonna get a paper cut that's pretty much
gonna be the worst thing that's gonna
happen to you right and it's just it's
amazing to me that's odd that that's all
that it took really it's just here this
is what you believe this is the book
this is your holy book that's all it
took yeah so when when they showed you
that and you looked at this was your
family like how religious was your
family how did your process of coming
out you know I've described this this
process that atheists have to come out
of the closet much like LGBTQ people do
that there is this hidden shame this
feeling of the other nasaan all that how
long did that take before you had the
realization versus when you told your
family your friends that kind of thing
well so as far as that terminology the
coming-out thing that's so common in
ex-muslim circles that's that's what we
use we say have you come out to you're
like you know do are you out of the
closet that is the language that we
because that's it that's the reality of
it isn't it yeah well it what I what I
did was I do just have debates with my
family here and there about specific
issues and that's how they sort of got
the message I don't know if I explicitly
said it for the first couple of years
but I was lucky I'm very lucky in that I
have a truly liberal father and by
liberal I mean okay I still wasn't
allowed to wear certain kinds of
clothing right I still couldn't wear
shorts in the house I still couldn't
have you know uh boyfriends or anything
like that or daytime I was expected to
get an arranged marriage and everything
where's the liberal part coming it's
coming that's that's liberal it's
liberal in the sense that he allowed me
to my father allowed me to read what I
wanted to read and he didn't question it
too much because he thought I would end
up in the right place at the end so that
was a sense of freedom and I only had to
fight for maybe a year or two to be able
to go away for college so that was that
was my liberal father god it's so funny
how it's so funny how terms and words
really mean a lot you know before you
refer it is you say something nice about
America the left will you know say
you're a neocon and in
this context you describe your liberal
father but you know you couldn't wear
shorts and that kind of stuff and yet
clearly within that space he was liberal
it's amazing
it was very liberal and he was very
liberal in the sense that he he gave me
a sort of dignity as a woman that I
think that wasn't given it isn't given
by many Muslim men to their daughters
and to their wives and my even mothers
and so I consider myself lucky I know
that sounds interesting but I do
consider myself very lucky that my
childhood was it was similar to maybe
what very conservative almost
fundamentalist Christians would have and
that I consider myself lucky that I
didn't I wasn't forced to wear the hijab
I I did wear it for a short amount of
time by choice but it wasn't forced upon
me um so it is it is interesting what we
consider liberal and what's considered
liberal anywhere else in the world yeah
and that's one of the interesting things
and one of the reasons why I wanted to
talk to you because you know there are
so many stories you hear about you know
X Christians leaving you hear about X
Jews leaving you know Orthodox Judaism
something like that where they're then
considered heroes on the left ah they
left this dogmatic conservative ideology
but you don't hear about many people
like you and I've recently connected
with a bunch and it's like you're so
obviously standing up for the basic
liberal values that we all talk about
all the time right it's it's so bizarre
to be in this space I mean I feel
strange that I'm here because I feel
like have enemies like people who just
don't like what I'm saying for one
reason or another and my narrative of
the is like you said classically liberal
one right it's it's something that on
the face of it should be something every
liberal should support but there is
there is such a tendency on the left to
protect Muslims to protect them from
bigotry and these fears of bigotry I
would say I mean they're they're real
rather it's not a it's not been I'm
making this up it is it is a fear and
it's a real fear but the response has
been what I would call a reactionary
it's interesting because they say I do
reactionary right and I think but but
your response to Islam is also very
reactionary you're also not looking at
it in some an objective point of view
yeah well it seems to me we've got the
reactionary
right and the regressive left but I want
to hold that for a second because I want
to talk about the speech that you gave
because it was really wonderful and I
saw blowing up on Twitter and a zillion
people were sending it to me and I
watched it again yesterday in
preparation for this and you know we
talked about this coming-out process but
I you sort of referenced that in this it
seemed to me like you obviously without
knowing you and this is the first time
we spoke but it seemed like your entire
life had led up to that very moment am I
being very dramatic there um well I it
was something that I was extremely
nervous doing I mean and I don't know I
think it showed in the video that I
showed that I was nervous and I was
because I felt ever since I've been
doing this activism now it's been three
years I've been doing ex-muslim activism
I am blindsided by the reaction of the
left I really thought you know and and
this is something that I hear from
activists everywhere I hear that they
thought they would come here and they
would talk to people on the left and
they would find allies I would find
people who are willing to support them
and we're willing to give at least moral
support if not anything else but they
would make their brothers and I found
that in so many ways people I considered
my brothers and my sisters in this
struggle have overlooked me for what
seems like a very political a very
political reason and the what I was
feeling and especially around the time I
was giving that speech it was after the
Charlie Hebdo shootings and I was
feeling extremely disheartened by the
sec even the secular community overall
that there are so many people that were
saying well you know they that in some
ways it could be justified and
Islamophobia Islamic phobia and all this
stuff that didn't really make a lot of
sense and I was feeling abandoned and so
I thought you know they gave me this
opportunity to have the speech so I'm
going to just speak my mind I think
maybe they expected me to talk a little
bit about mostly about my organization
but I ended up sort of hijacking that
conversation and talking about that yeah
well I first off I mean I recommend that
everyone that's watching this should
absolutely watch that because we can
only touch on on some of what you what
you did there but the reaction from the
left you know it's a lot of what we've
spent this show talking about and the
more that I try to get away from it you
know I've tried to address
it so that I could move away from it I
want these people to understand that
someone like you that someone like me
that we we are standing up for liberal
values but it's not just that they've
ignored you in a lot of ways these
people have sort of actively tried to
undermine you don't you think right and
then and there is it's it's not just
undermining it's it's slimming
right and there's people that have
questioned my agenda and what am i what
am I doing this for I mean I don't you
know I don't I'm not gaining anything
from this I mean in a lot of ways this
comes at a high personal cost many
ex-muslim that speak out but there are
so many people there that are very
intent on painting me as a right wing
show and I get this all the time and I
even get this from people who I thought
would be my allies from atheists from
leftists so it's like what do you make
of that tactic just that general tactic
that it's not about what you say because
if anyone was to listen to that speech
or hopefully anything that we're going
to talk about here I'm gonna guess that
you're gonna line up with liberal values
99% of the time so it's rarely about
what you say it's about who you are and
that you don't fit into their neat
little box of what a Muslim should
believe which is crazy to me well I
actually disagree with you I think it is
what you say in the sense that if you're
talking negatively about Islam at all at
all from any perspective right it matter
if you're fueled by human rights or
fueled by bigoted or whatever it doesn't
matter if you are touching negatively on
Islam on any level you are a bigot right
matter how you say it because a lot of
people say this to me they say well what
would you tell you know Richard Dawkins
or Sam Harris you know do you think
there's a way they can say their
critique that would be beneficial and
what I tell them is or what I ask them
instead is well can you think of
somebody who has directly a critiqued
Islam in it in a direct way I that has
gotten away with it that hasn't been
called a bigot by something you know how
do you how what is the right way of
saying this point me to an example of
somebody who's critiquing Islam and it
hasn't been able to you know get away
and still retain their liberal
credentials yeah and that's the part of
this that drives me nuts because you
know when I started the show only a
couple months ago
my intention was not to talk about this
stuff this much but as I said I can't
get out of it because as a liberal I see
people like you and I say this is this
is the the very people regardless of
your religion if you were an X Christian
as I said or if you were an X - I would
feel the same way about the principles
that you're standing up for so you know
I laid out some principles when we
started the show that I wasn't going to
talk about people that much specific
people except in this space there have
been a couple people that have have
acted really really dishonestly and I
read just a couple days ago a piece that
you wrote about some of the stuff that
reza aslan has said and i find him to be
a profoundly dishonest player in this
space and I see what he's done to Sam
Harris most of my audience knows about
all of that already can you explain a
little bit about what your what your
stuff is with him uh well so this was in
response to I wrote I co-wrote a piece
with Mohammed saya who's also works with
X Muslims of North America there was
there's a CNN clip that's been going
around and it's making rounds again at
the CNN clip where Reza Aslan is on and
he talks about FGM and he talks about
Bill Maher and talks about how FGM isn't
and isn't a Muslim problem it's an
African problem female genital
mutilation we should just say it for the
few people that may not right yeah any
and then he he puts a few other things
out there as evidence that Muslim
majority countries are actually not that
bad for women including you know their
song women that are heads of state and
etc so I wrote a piece about it Co wrote
a piece about it and published it on the
Friendly Atheist and it got this big
response because I feel like there were
some people that a good amount of people
that were wanting somebody to pick up on
these things that they felt like weren't
true nothing they couldn't say this and
we said it and we laid it out there and
we laid out very clearly about why the
points that he was making were dishonest
at the you know at the least and I think
in a lot of ways he's aware of what
doing so he said he said many times that
you know Muhammad he's something to the
extent of you know how Muhammad freed
the slaves he said things in that vein
quite a few times and that is extremely
dishonest that is not true it's just not
true all Mohammed did would say that you
can't enslave another Muslim and there
are many people many scholars who think
that this actually encouraged the spread
of the slave trade because suddenly
you're in Arabia and you can slave and
enslave another Muslim so you have to go
out and you rekon you have to go to
various places to get your slaves and he
did that he didn't condemn slavery he
had slaves he had sex slaves and so
there and supposedly reza aslan is a
scholar i don't even know about that
whole thing I can't I can't waste any
more brain cells on that guy basically
right it's just so it's very frustrating
and talking about a red lesson I'm
getting tired of it myself just to see
that oh you just you just make stuff up
sometime what do you think that's part
of the reason I wanted to mention it
because I knew you were gonna be
exhausted by talking about it because
it's like you write your piece and then
you want to move on and that's how I
felt a lot of with a lot of my
interviews I interviewed Sam and I
wanted to move on to some other stuff
but then these guys just further the
attack but do you think that that's part
of it that they throw out what I would
call just basic [ __ ] or they throw
out these lies and these smears and then
you have to spend a tremendous amount of
your time and your energy and your
lifeforce basically either defending
yourself or the honest critiques that
you're making absolutely and I think
this is the experience of almost
everyone who has critique Islam in any
way and which is why we're seeing
there's just a lack of it there's just a
lack of it everywhere I mean there's a
lack of scholarship if you try to really
study this and I have there there isn't
that much out there that is truly
secular that is looking at it from a
very outsider's perspective there were
some efforts to do so but they've now
been painted as orientalist and
therefore bad and therefore right-wing
of course so and so there's that study
sort of stopped around the time that
those smears began and those
associations with this is bigotry if
you're going to conflate this with any
kind of negative any kind of negative
anything so
it's I think it's it's really
unfortunate because a scholarly pursuit
of looking into you know what Islam is
how did it began what Muhammad did all
of that I mean that has just it suffered
it suffered tremendously because of
people's fears of being seen as a
bigoted racist whatever so a lot of I
think a lot of people haven't haven't
really reached out haven't really said
the things that they want to say reveal
the knowledge that they had or even
looked into it further if they wanted to
because if they're they're thinking well
this is going to destroy my career
what's the point yeah and doesn't some
of that that fear of speaking out about
this stuff doesn't that actually show
what real bigotry is if you're afraid to
speak out about saying because you think
it's going to lead to dishonest smearing
of you or really what it's about is
violence to you that's what people
clearly are really afraid I mean I get
emails now every day literally from all
over the world that people are afraid to
speak out so the real bigotry is saying
we're not going to talk about these
people because guess what they can't
control their violent tendencies or
something like that right alright and
well it's interesting cuz a lot of
people said this about about the Charlie
Hebdo the cartoonists they said well
they should have seen it coming John
Kerry John Kerry our Secretary of State
just in the last day or so said
basically you know there was some sort
of rationalization it's unbelievable
it's absolutely unbelievable and to say
that that you have it coming when you
are exercising a right exercising a
right that is given to you in the
country that you live and what's the
point of having a right if I can't test
it to its extremes that's the point and
in a lot of ways what Charlie Hebdo did
for example was not that extreme it was
exactly the same treatment that they
were giving Christianity and they were
giving that exact same treatment to to
Islam so it to me it seemed like they
were they were making it fair they were
saying that hey we're not biased and
we're gonna apply the same the same
scrutiny to all religious forms and they
did that and I thought they were very
fair about it and then they have smeared
in so many ways yeah and not only did
they do it out of equality where they
made fun of Orthodox Jews and made fun
of Christianity I think I'm going to
slightly butcher this but I think it was
something like 80% were about
Christianity when they did covers
related to religion and only something
like ten
and were about Islam but I don't quote
me fully on that but also what people
fail to realize with Charlie Hebdo is
that it was satire about the things that
are wrong with religion they weren't
mocking Muslims as people just as they
weren't mocking Christians as people but
they were mocking archaic age-old ideas
right right absolutely in many ways I
think it can be seen as an anti-racist
publication and and and a lot of people
made a lot of good cases for this and
it's difficult because we're
english-speaking people and we don't
really understand the context of how how
they how you know these publishers do
what they do in France but I think when
you look at it from in from a very
unbiased perspective you'll find that
there are anti-racist in a lot of ways
and it was horrible to hear people say
well they had it coming because it it
made it seem not only that they were
stupid for doing what they're doing
instead of brave which is what they were
yeah but but also that Muslims are
beasts and animals and we cannot expect
them to behave in the same way we would
expect everyone else to behave right and
that's what I mean about this sort of
soft I think this is what Bill Maher
refers to as the soft bigotry of low
expectations if you say anything about
these people that's going to upset them
well then you have to just expect that
they're gonna kill you and that that's
crazy and also you would live in a
constant hostage crisis with a certain
set of the population absolutely and
that's that I mean that's exactly the
feeling of I think a lot of those people
who tell you that you know I'm afraid to
speak out
it is absolutely taking away from the
humanity of Muslims too because it's
turning them into beasts that we cannot
we cannot say hey this is a standard
that we expect from everybody we expect
you to be able to handle this and that
they listen to it okay and we actually
haven't pushed it we actually haven't
said that hey this is totally acceptable
and this is totally what how we run
things in the Western world and this is
what we expect out of everyone who is
here in the Western world we expect you
to respect us especially not respond in
a violent way women haven't had that
conversation so is part of it simply
that for the people that are the real
Islamic extremists they simply at the
end of the day no matter how much my
friends on the left want to blame
everything on American foreign policy
and all of this stuff no matter you know
Boko Haram killed about 160 people last
week it had nothing to do with American
foreign policy right yet this is they
always blame everything on America and I
don't deny as I said at the top of the
show I don't deny that foreign policy
has mucked up a lot of things but this
is where people on the Left just
completely fail right absolutely and I'm
I'm very I'm sick of hearing that
colonialism is to blame for all of this
I'm sick of it that one particular thing
I hear all the time that this is it's
because of colonialism and it doesn't
really make any sense when you look into
it and again not to say not to say that
colonialism was in a horrible horrible
practice I mean I'm from the South Asian
subcontinent so colonized by England and
it was horrible what England did to to
South Asia and and the effects the
long-range effects it had on South Asia
but they're so easy to throw away the
colonialism excuse when it comes to
radical Islam I mean I mentioned two of
these in my speech which is that Muslims
have been doing this sort of thing
violence justifying violence in the name
of religion since way before colonialism
ever came into the picture right that
it's existed for a long long time and
when you say colonialism is the only
thing to blame you are denying that that
whole history existed but there were so
many people that were oppressed in the
name of Islam it's happened before and
it's happening again it's the same sort
of thing yeah did you by any chance see
a piece that Faisal Scytale Matar put up
a couple days ago on Facebook where he
writes sort of a satirical piece saying
that he's playing this this Muslim
extremists saying this is why I'm doing
it I'm doing it for religion and it's
basically this argument with him and one
of these regressive lefties saying no no
no no it's not because a religion and he
keeps saying no no I'm doing it cuz a
religion and they go back and forth and
go back and forth and at the end the
guys like you know what do I have to do
to prove to you that this is in the name
of religion I mean even after Paris
which I want to talk to about a second
the statement that these guys issued
there was a lot of religious overtones
to it a ton of religious overtones it
wasn't purely you know this bombing in
Syria or whatever well it's I mean it's
astounding to me that at this point
anyone can deny that religion is nothing
to deal with it I true I I believe that
every there is no one really any serious
intellectual who believes it this has
nothing to do with the religion it has
something you know you can even make the
case that it's a perverted Islam but it
is some aspect of Islamic theology that
they have taken and then perverted at
the very least at the very least that
they have done that and I think that a
lot of people play just lip service they
say that this has nothing to do with a
religion I don't think they believe it I
think this is in a lot of ways a very
political loop yeah so I mentioned this
also at the top of the show but if let's
say magically the United States and the
West and France and England and
everybody we all did
whatever it is Isis wants us to do
United mean pull out of that part of the
world whatever else they might want us
to do do have any reason to believe that
suddenly terror would stop or that
things would get better I actually would
see it completely the reverse they would
almost be more emboldened to continue
and I say that as someone that doesn't
even want to be there in the first place
right I agree with you about Isis is a
different animal and if they are they
are very strict about their
interpretation and they look into things
at in a very literal way and if they are
going to look into it as in the way that
you know Islamic thought has progressed
about what you would call the land of
the most believers and land of the
non-believers they are religiously it's
a duty it's a religious duty to do what
they can't despite Islam to at the whole
globe so they're not going to stop their
toll that's they're not going to stop
why can't we just listen to them and
understand that they mean what they say
yeah and that was the point of faizal's
peace and I got into a fight on Twitter
I try not to fight on Twitter but I got
into a fight with one of my friends on
the Left who kept saying foreign policy
and I kept saying listen to what they're
saying don't listen to me listen listen
to what they tell you so one more I just
want to jump back a little bit before we
get into into Paris so I want people to
understand there's a distinction between
someone like yourself that you consider
yourself an ex-muslim you are a
non-believer versus some of the
Reformers that are still either either
believers or that consider themselves
Muslim someone like imagine Waze
although he said to me that you know he
doesn't
I put up his version of Islam for anyone
else but but there is a distinction
there so there's two brands of people
that we're talking about that are trying
to help here right do you mean like
progressive Muslims and and well-meaning
meaning that there's there's your branch
that sort of X Muslims right you fully
you are an atheist you don't consider
yourself part of the religion versus
there are some that are trying to reform
the religion from the inside is there
any sort of interplay with you guys are
people working together it's hard to
tell well I think that I think it would
be intellectually dishonest for us to
work together in the sense that truly
our aims are different yeah I mean
they're they're similar in some ways
right we want to make sure we want to
decrease harm in the world we want to
push secularism push Human Rights
promote it the best we can but our ways
of going about it are so radically
different that I think that it would be
I mean we're I'm in contact with with
some of these people and I respect them
tremendously yeah you're doing wonderful
things I disagree with them there is
very little about Islam and fundamentals
of Islam as as as sam harris says that i
agree with on any level and it's hard
for me to find any beauty or or you know
compassion or all these wonderful things
that we would ascribe to something so
holy i don't i don't find that in this
text so there isn't really i disagree
with people when they do say that I'm a
little bit extremist you know people say
that well you cannot expect everyone to
just a pasta is all at once but this is
not what I'm pushing I don't want the
Muslim world to apostatize all at once
yeah but but for me it would be
intellectually dishonest to go about it
on any other way and I actually think
that there is I mean it's atheism and
secularism and free thought I think we
have a very strong critique of religion
something that is very internally
coherent and ethically coherent and this
case is one worth making and if we're
talking about the marketplace of ideas
it's important that we show our side and
we put their best case out there and the
land where they'll land so that that's
really interesting to me so in a weird
way your your brand
here is a little is a little cleaner
let's say then the people that are
trying to reform it from the inside and
I don't sense that you're judging them
for that as much as it really is easier
to make a case from your position
because you're just saying I don't
believe in thousand-year-old books so
I'm going to make a case based on the
world as it is sort of and they're still
trying to negotiate and that's what I
see someone like Reza and where I say he
this is someone who's profoundly
dishonest all the time but I think he's
trying to negotiate the world with this
religion and then he uses a lot of words
so nobody knows what he's talking about
but your case is a lot cleaner even even
if I disagreed with you I would
understand the logic more sensibly I do
think that in the case of somebody like
Reza I think it is condescending towards
other Muslims because I think some
people believe that you know Muslims
will never get there they'll never get
to where you are you're expecting too
much I don't think I'm expecting too
much like this is actually if I was
allowed to make this case most Muslims
do not hear anything similar to what I
have to say they will never hear
anything like this I think if they did I
think it would change things yeah
they we don't know yet right and we
don't we don't know that that's the case
right well now you did this show with me
they're gonna say you're working with a
Zionist Nazi and not enough this is
gonna help now either tell me a little
bit about being a woman in this space
because you have a double a double edged
sword so to speak here because leaving a
religion any religion stuff but
particularly tough to leave Islam and
then when you couple that with all the
stuff related to being a woman and being
a secular woman in America in 2015 isn't
that easy sometimes how does that play
into how you how you live well let me
start by saying there's so many people
that I'm connected to through my through
the organization and through meeting a
bunch of X Muslims I mean idea I don't
think you'd be a stretch to say that I
probably know more X Muslims than most
people you know the world you know will
ever know right that and and what I what
I hear consistently from a lot of women
that the reason that they left the
religion was because of the treatment of
women and a lot of it just didn't make
any sense and they didn't they didn't
appreciate they felt that they weren't
being given the same kind of dignity as
as men and when they looked at it from
that perspective things change feminism
hello
with it which is very interesting when
we talk about today is feminism here big
yeah but really found the feminist
allies in the West that I thought I
would find I expected for them to be the
first people to run to my defense and if
you have but a small few I expected
there to be big valley with the you know
feminists from all over to come and talk
about these issues but I haven't found
that to be the case at all is very
disheartening yeah so what is that
strange alliance because you see this
all the time you know a group like code
pink that stands for women's rights an
anti-war you would think they would be
standing for women's rights all over the
globe but instead they'll rant and rave
and you know talk about Gaza meanwhile
if they ever went to Gaza I'm pretty
sure that these women would not be
treated particularly well so this double
standard just endlessly exists huh
yeah absolutely and I I think it's it's
it's very like I said it's disheartening
for one and because I was somebody that
that feminism was a huge part of me
leaving religion it was a huge part of
me a fuelling me and the women's rights
causes of fueling me into my activism
it's been especially painful to see that
feminists are not always on my on the
same level as me what I have found is
that there's a lot of posts about women
that say the Muslim women that say that
they're empowered by the hijab you know
and there would be they'll be on
feminist websites they'll say you know
I'm very empowered you're just a job and
it's my political whatever and you know
it to me it's it's wonderful for that
particular woman if she feels that this
is her choice and this is what she wants
to do and this is how she wants to live
her life that's great but Muslim women
that's wearing the job of making a piece
like that is like a woman in you know
1930s America saying that I'm proud to
be a housewife I love staying home with
my children this is exactly where I want
to be well good for you maybe you do and
that's wonderful
it's good for you that everything in
society aligned with your desire
perfectly right oh you and now you get
to live this wonderful life but you have
to acknowledge the 1930s America women
way we wanted to have a career weren't
as free to do so that there were so many
different factors that were put making
it's very very
difficult for them to live the life the
way they wanted to you have to be able
to acknowledge that in that same way I
want these kajabi women to be able to
acknowledge that they there's so many
women who don't ascribe to these modesty
codes and they aren't free to live lives
the way they want yeah
well and this again this is why the left
has put themselves or this regressive
left has put themselves in such a crazy
box they should be defending women's
options they don't have to say you have
to live a certain way but they should at
least give you the options and that's
also why they've been relentless on New
Atheists oh you get it now as a woman
you get it as an ex-muslim
I don't know if you identify
specifically with a new atheist with new
atheism you consider yourself a new
atheist what does that even mean I'm not
sure exactly nobody nobody really seems
to know the best way I can describe it
now as at least as I've come to
understand it is that it's an atheist
who is finally speaking up so for that
for that version that's what I would
consider myself but but the community
the left really has been attacking
atheist too so you're on a like a you're
like spinning and you got shots from all
sides huh I definitely feel that way I
mean I don't want to talk about how big
of a victim I am because I don't like
those kinds of politics but but in
general I have felt that the people that
on paper should be supporting me and I
looked into this actually as a response
to seeing the way that left it I've
reacted I started do more research on
what liberal principles were and really
trying to get a grounding on what it
meant to be a liberal and I feel and
Bill Mara said this so many time he said
I'm the real liberal and I think he's
right he's right when he says he's a
real liberal and I feel like I'm a real
liberal yeah so you're not gross and
racist that's what you're telling me Oh
God that I was so bad that was so bad
and - okay here's it's years when I was
watching that I kind of felt I'm gonna
get haters for this but I kind of or
Banasik a little bit I kind of had
always cute that he's standing up he
thinks he's standing up for the poor
oppressed minority right that's my ex
he's doing that's what he's really
convinced that he's standing up for an
oppressed group and it's nice that he
has good intentions but it's nice I
appreciate that
but he's so wrong and he's really
hurting the same
he's and he's not understanding exactly
what's going on here and it was very
interesting in that particular scenario
to see Sam and then very emotional venez
like very very emotional when a fly can
very calm Sam Harris you know I think
you'll find this interesting I was
discussing this with first off I
discussed it with Sam himself but I also
discussed it with Joe Rogan a couple
weeks ago on his show and I said what
you just said I said well you know I
think he was trying to do the right
thing and trying to and maybe he got too
emotional but you know he was trying to
stand up for the downtrodden that kind
of thing and joe said something that I
now fully believe I mean he got me to
change my opinion like that he said no
he's like man I know actors I'm around
actors they fake this so that everyone
will just think they're so holy they're
so benevolent they're so wonderful and
all that and and he was really convinced
that that's what Ben was doing there but
I don't I don't want to waste any more
any more time on that specifically so
the Atheist stuff yeah you're getting
you're getting it from them you're
getting it from the other guys what can
we do then what what can secular people
and free thinkers do because I know that
people just by listening to this a
certain subset of people are going to
say all the things that you laid out at
the beginning they're going to say that
I hate Muslims that you're a secret
Zionist all of this nonsense but what
can we do
I guess just talk right I mean it's
really that the best we can do
absolutely I think just be
intellectually honest and I think that a
lot of people understand what I mean
when I say that because people stop
themselves they want to say these things
they have these opinions and the
reaction that I got to my speech at the
American Humanist Association the
biggest reaction was you said what I
wanted to say yeah you you put the words
that I was thinking in my head but I
just felt like I couldn't
I really couldn't articulate and I felt
trapped and you said those things so it
felt like a release you know for for me
to hear you say it for to hear somebody
say it and I think that if we can be
brave and if we can talk about it and
especially liberals it is very important
that it is liberals who stand up for
this because we are the compassionate
ones right well that really are keeping
the harm of that of the people in place
we are not forgetting about
anti-muslim bigotry that is something
that is that is obviously at the
forefront of my of our minds we know
that because that's why we're not saying
anything about this yeah right of this
harm yes it is those particularly those
people that need to be speaking out they
need to be making this nuanced
discussion right and that's what it
seems so obvious to me that I don't have
to twist my beliefs to say the things
that I'm saying to you everything that
I'm saying to you and I sense everything
that you're saying to me is based in the
same set of secular principles that you
apply to everything else and for some
reason these guys want you to just be a
little more careful when it comes to
this set of ideas but what I see is the
real danger there is that if we don't
speak up right now and we're added we're
an extremely precarious moment right now
with everything going on in Paris and
with Isis and all that that if we don't
speak up we hand the future to the
people on the right nothing absolutely
there they're getting empowered by this
because people are not stupid we are
seeing that there is this big elephant
in the room that people we cannot talk
about that the media isn't talking about
what are we doing we're building
distrust of your average American
citizen when they're watching their TV
screens and they're not seeing anybody
but Fox News really talking about Islam
in a way that feels remotely honest
right and and it's horrible it's
horrible that we're giving this up to
these people who really have some
xenophobic motives maybe that you know
and we need to make sure that it is us
that are talking about this that are
engaging with this issue it's it's
similar I think what happened with a tea
party I think there was some real hurt
and some real pain right after you know
the economic downturn and I think a lot
of people were feeling abandoned by
their government and I think we could
have III even say now we could have
seized on that moment and we could have
made it a populist progressive movement
to take down you know corporations or
whatever it is we could have we could
have harnessed it but instead we disdain
those people because they were you know
backwater
bigots whatever people who were very
uncommon but they don't understand
things in a nuanced complicated way the
way that everyone else does and so we
find it very easy to to to just push
them aside and dismiss them and look at
what happened there right they became a
political force that a lot of people
would say had done some harm yeah
political spectrum so we don't want that
happening again yeah I don't know if you
saw my video about it a couple weeks ago
but I said that the regressive left is
our Tea Party and I don't want what has
happened to the right that has been
dragged off the deep end I don't want
that happening to my side that's why I
do think we're at this moment so I know
we only have a little bit left but I do
want to focus on Paris a little bit I
know you're not you're not a terrorist
expert or something of that nature but
in terms of the human part of this that
it sounds like a lot of these people did
grow up in Paris they are in France they
grew up in the West some of them grew up
in Belgium but they grew up in Western
societies what do you make of that kind
of radicalization because you know I
know a lot of the debate right now is
about can we let refugees in are we
going to let terrorists in with refugees
and that but there's also a homegrown
problem right now that we're not dealing
with yeah I this is my in just my
opinion and again I'm not a scholar on
this but I feel like what there are many
young people in different parts of
Europe especially and I think you're
particularly that feel that they are and
a lot of people say they're between two
cultures that's the fray that people use
at they're between this Western culture
and their culture back home but I I
don't think that that's the truth I
think that the truth is that they don't
really have any they don't really have
any viable options they don't really
believe in the same stuff that that
their parents might have done from
Pakistan or whatever and they don't
really fit in with the community in in
the West and they sort of feel lost by
this multicultural narrative right that
if we can push and then a lot of people
do have the specific critique they say
that we have lost our bearings we have
lost our values we don't really push our
story and our values in our you know and
on our way of looking at the world we
don't really advocate for that in the
way that it deserves to be advocated for
and I think these are the people that
are there the lost children of this
because these are people who don't have
anything to don't have anything to latch
on to what they do have to latch onto is
if somebody comes and says this Islamist
narrative and everything makes so much
sense and it's everything is so clear
now and they can grapple onto it I think
you've covered this so many times you
talked about this
about freedom of speech issues about how
we're not allowed to talk about certain
ideas I think it's so harmful that we're
not allowed to talk about critique of
religion critique of Islam because we're
then we're giving up this ground to to
the Islamists we're letting them give
these people these these great
narratives that they'll latch on to and
they don't have any opposing narrative
at all yeah so what so what do we do I
mean really what are the secularists do
I know that there are some organizations
like the one that margins involved in
that are trying to deer a decline with
you I get it that it's it's a
compounding of economic issues and and
religious narrative and imperial it's
all of these things but how do we move
forward because the talking as we're
doing it's good for now but at some
point we got to get to these to the kids
I guess the younger generation well this
is something I get gets related to the
Syrian refugees that are coming in a lot
of people are very worried about the
effect that these refugees will have on
the countries and I think the only
long-term way of proceeding and making
sure that we don't have the same kind of
problems is to push emergent as much as
we can which means that we don't allow
them to build these isolated little
communities we spread them out within
within the the country and we pull them
in into the you know American Way of
life or Western Way life what have you
in that sense I think a lot of these
multicultural narratives are very very
very harmful I think we need to discard
them immediately there's a lot of this
there's a lot of hesitancy we know we
know how to pull immigrants in and how
to immerse them into our our society we
know that there's so much there's so
much work about this and scholarly stuff
about this written about this we can do
it sure we're a nation of immigrants
they want to write every one of us every
one of us here in America we either are
from immigrants or we were brought over
as slaves or we're Native Americans but
but the large majority of us are
immigrants right and you know what
because what happened was America pulled
us in and said well here's the stuff I
don't like but here's the stuff I do
like and they pulled it together and we
became this nation that is so powerful
and then what you have
instead in places like the UK is if
these mini nations that are not a part
of the overall you know Britain's
British society there's little Pakistani
community and a little North African
community and they sort of live as if
they were back in Pakistan or Bangladesh
or whatever it is and that I think is so
harmful because these people never feel
like everyone else that I feel like an
American and I don't think everyone else
does and I want them to feel that way I
want them to feel like an American yeah
it's an interesting it's almost like a
self-fulfilling prophecy because then
when when the British people go in and
try and go move into that community then
they feel like those people in that
community feel like they're under attack
or something or they have to defend
their their little area so you have this
constant battle of you know of the self
versus the the bigger community and what
it was happened that we've given up the
battle right we've just said okay we'll
just live however you want to live
you're just different people and you
just operate on different rules and
you're different concepts of human
rights and that's just we're just gonna
turn a blind eye that's what's happened
in the UK I yeah and we can't do it
anymore right no we have to have these I
mean we've always had with these
immigrant communities in the United
States negotiations use back and forth
within these scuffles and sometimes
they've been very painful but in the end
we're stronger and the immigrant
community gets immersed and is stronger
too
yeah all right so my final thought would
be I've been trying to end all my
conversations on a note of positiveness
and I think you've actually given a lot
of hope throughout here but I definitely
sense that the tide is turning I know it
feels like a dangerous time right now
there's there's so much craziness going
on and with the internet everything
feels smaller so when something happens
5,000 miles away it seems like it
happened in your backyard but I do sense
something good here the fact that we've
connected the fact that all of these
people now that we're all in the same
circles and we're all talking and our
circles are getting bigger I do feel
like maybe the tide will turn in our
favor do you do you feel that give me
something good to end on here I think I
think you're absolutely right you've
mentioned this before I noticed that
things are changing and I feel this I
think Majin was it said it too before
where he said the left is changing and
he feels this you can sort of you can
sense it in the air that there's Diskin
out there that there's people were
suddenly there's a lot of dissonance
going on yeah was mindin we want it to
make sense and I think that we're giving
you know this point of view that we're
giving is one that is so much more clear
and it's so much better for people and
better for Humanity and I think people
will will slowly gravitate towards it
yeah you know it's funny I did a video
on free speech last week and at the end
I referenced you know all of this stuff
with safe spaces and trigger warnings
and all this nonsense and it's like when
I speak to someone like you and I speak
to majid and ayaan and Sam and all you
guys I said in the video I was like look
guys watch my videos with these people
if you think these are the extremists
then there's something wrong with you
it's not something wrong with them you
know my Jen Sam just wrote a book called
the Islam in the future of Tolerance it
wasn't called Islam and the future of
you know weapons of mass destruction you
know anyway well it's an absolute
pleasure I'm so glad we connected and
we're able to do this and you're doing
such great work ah thank you so much
thank you so much for having me yeah so
it's at Sarah the hater on Twitter and
everyone should check out your group
which is X Muslims of North America and
we're gonna stay in the loop and next
time you know LA dinner's on me all
right all right thanks a lot
you